PROFESSOR: This class is talking
about two lectures, both about
protein folding, fixed angled
chains, things like that.
There's a few
questions about them.
One is mostly about
these open problems,
equilateral, equiangular,
obtuse 3D chains,
fixed angle open problem
is, are they locked?
So the question is about,
what about any subset
of those combinations?
So this originally comes
from an open problem
I think posed in 1999, one of
the first 3D linkage papers,
and it asked whether equilateral
universal joints can lock,
and that's still open.
For universal joints,
these two constraints
don't make a lot of
sense because who
cares if it's
initially equiangular.
As soon as you move it, it
will no longer be equiangular.
And obtuseness I don't
think matters too much,
although it potentially could.
So for that problem, equilateral
seems to be the core.
For fixed angle,
though, we conjecture
that fixed angle equilateral is
not enough from this example.
It's still not
proved to be locked.
I don't know if it's hard,
but it's probably tedious,
so it hasn't been done.
This was the crossed
legs example.
All the edge lengths
are the same,
and if you don't allow
the touching part,
then all the angles
are also the same.
So this is everything
except the obtuse property
and it's probably locked, so
dropping obtuse is no good.
The other things you could drop
are equilateral or equiangular.
This is if you drop equiangular.
Fixed angle equilateral is
not terribly constraining
because you can
simulate a long bar
by having a lot of
180 degree angles.
This is obtuse and
it's equilateral
but it's not
equiangular and it's
locked for a trivial reason.
So this is dropping equiangular.
If I drop equilateral,
I can also
just make a knitting
needles example.
I take a really long link, and
this thing is basically string,
so I don't really care.
This connection can be done
with a lot of obtuse angles,
and then have a
really long link.
So dropping any of
the three constraints
makes it easy to lock, so
for fixed angle chains,
you need equilateral,
equiangular, and obtuse.
All these things
together potentially mean
you're not locked,
but we don't know.
That's the open problem.
Of course, we don't
necessarily need
exactly equilateral
or equiangular.
Hopefully, within some small min
to max ratio would be enough,
but we don't know.
Next question is, why did we
model the ribosome as a cone?
That seems rather simple.
Is this realistic?
And partly, when I
taught the class in 2010,
I didn't use any images I
couldn't get permission for.
This year I'm more lax.
We'll ask for forgiveness
instead of permission.
This is a paper
from Science 2000.
This is what the ribosome
actually looks like.
There's many different
figures of it,
but I particularly like this
one because it highlights
a tunnel in the center
of the ribosome.
And so the idea is this is a
machine for converting MRNA
into your proteins,
and the idea is
the protein comes through here.
There's a little
bump in the tunnel.
Some people conjecture this
is where the amino acid gets
attached, and then
it feeds through here
and starts spitting out.
And as I said, there's
barely enough room
here for an alpha helix, so
probably not too much folding
happens inside and the folding
should just happen over here.
And the observation is if
you have a reasonable size
protein that's only going
to be about this big,
then there's this big,
flat wall at the exit,
so you have a plane
there and this half space
is more or less a big obstacle.
It's the alpha cone model
where alpha is 180, I think,
if alpha is the half angle.
So it's not really a cone.
It's a cone that's been opened
up all the way to a plane,
but that's one of the situations
that's handled by the theorems
that we talked about.
So that's why the cone model.
We generalize to
cones just because it
works for general
cones, but the real one
is a sort of flat cone.
That's where that comes from.
I think actually we proved the
theorem before we knew this,
but then we looked it
up and it was true.
And the last question
is about the lecture 21,
which some of you may not have
watched because it's optional,
but there's this model
called the HP model
for protein folding.
It's a model of
protein energy and it
says you have a chain
of H and P nodes,
and basically, the H nodes
are attracted to each other
and the P nodes don't care.
And the model is that the H
nodes are hydrophobic so they
want to be next to each other
so they're not next to water,
which is surrounding
the whole molecule,
and the P nodes don't care,
or they're hydrophilic.
And it's known that if
you have an HP string
and you want to find the optimal
folding into a 2D or a 3D
structure, that's NP-hard,
which is kind of weird
because somehow
nature does it, maybe
because it found the easy
instances by evolution,
or maybe there's
something we're missing.
This model doesn't
capture reality.
We don't know.
But it captures part of reality,
as least as we observe it.
Unfortunately, these
hardness proofs
are a little too
complicated to cover here,
but I can at least answer
what are they reducing from.
There's two proofs.
I guess they were basically the
same time, I think around 2001.
The first one here
is in 3D, and these
are by two MIT professors.
There's this big construction
but the reduction
is from bin packing.
So you have a bunch
of fixed size bins
and you have a bunch of
items of varying sizes
and you just want
to fit them all
in using the fewest
bins possible.
And the rough idea of the
construction of this one, this
is how an individual
number is represented.
The rough idea is you
have this big cube.
You fill the sides
with stuff to protect
from the outside boundary.
The insides are just
used for connections,
and then the front face
here is this stuff.
You construct
these bins, and you
construct numbers which
have to fit inside the bins.
That's the rough idea.
The details are complicated.
The 2D proof by
several people is
from Hamiltonicity in
maximum degree-4 graphs.
So you have a graph
for every vertex that
has at most four incident edges.
You want to find a
Hamiltonian cycle, I think.
It's much harder to see
this picture, I would say.
There's no one diagram
that summarizes it.
This is roughly
the construction,
which is quite complicated,
and I'll just leave it at that.
That's what they're
reduced from.
I think an interesting
open problem
would be to find a simple or
cleaner proof of these results.
Now that it's known
that they're hard,
it's probably easy
or hardness proofs.
There's also some open
questions from lecture,
like is it APX hard?
Is it approximable to a 1
plus epsilon factor or 1 minus
epsilon factor for any
epsilon or is there
some limit to approximability?
We saw a nice approximation
4/3 whatever, 3/4 whatever,
but can you do better?
Still open.
So that was the questions,
and then this is a question
that you usually ask
in every lecture.
You didn't actually
ask it on this one,
but I copied and pasted.
So there's some
interesting progress
from this class two years ago,
and I think in the open problem
session initially, probably
also a class project
related to this part.
So this is back in lecture 20.
We had this proof,
which is kind of fun,
that flattening a
fixed angle chain,
deciding whether there
was a flat folded state,
is weakly NP hard,
weakly meaning
it depended a lot on what
these numbers look like
and it was a reduction
from partitions.
You had to split up the
numbers into two equal parts,
and if you did, then this
key would fit in the slot
and you're OK.
If you didn't, the key would
collide with something here.
So this means the
problem is hard
if your edge lengths
are vastly different.
They would have to differ
by a ratio of exponential
in the number of edges for
this to really be hard.
So a natural question is,
well, what if all the lengths
are equal, equilateral chains?
Turns out that is still hard,
and this is a paper just
published last year with
Sarah Eisenstadt, who
took the class then.
And there's a bunch
of results here.
All of these are NP hardness
results, strong NP hardness,
so it doesn't depend
on the numbers.
We've got flattening results.
There's also min flat
span and max flat span.
Once you have that
flattening is hard,
these are pretty
easy to show hard,
so I won't talk
about them so much.
But basically, we consider
different ranges of angles
and what you might allow.
In some cases, we can get
perfect equilateral chains.
In some cases, they have to
range between, say, 1 and 2
in length.
A natural question
is obtuse angles.
We don't quite know that.
The best we have is 60 degrees
minus epsilon and larger.
This is nice for
orthogonal chains,
but it's not for
chains, it's for trees.
So still some open questions
here, but lots of hardness
results.
I thought I'd show you roughly
what the hardness proofs look
like because
they're kind of fun.
They all follow this
kind of structure.
This is a gadget, and
it's a fixed angle chain.
Here I'm going to show
everything with 90 degrees
because it's easier
to think about.
And it's kind of like--
I'm thinking plunger,
but it's something like that.
You can decide which
parts get pushed in
and which parts get popped out,
and this L shape can basically
shift left and right to
three different places
if I did it right-- this
one, this one, and this one.
So that's a useful construction,
as you might imagine,
and the idea is you take that
and you add on these guys.
So I've got another kind
of plungey thing like this,
and this guy can move left
and right to various extents.
That's not very intuitive.
So then this connects
to these little guys,
and these can just
flip up or down
if it's a flat embedding
of a fixed angle chain.
And so the idea is you have
three of these pokey elements
and they can attach.
They bump into these
different things.
And if it's up,
then this can be up,
but when they're down-- like
this guy is currently down,
but it could be pushed
up-- then this guy
must be flipped down like that.
That's the rough idea of how
these parts fit together.
And so then this is how you end
up building some kind of three
sat problem.
So you have some variables.
They can either
be true or false.
And the idea is that the
true guys are on the top,
the bottom guys
are on the bottom,
and there's some complicated
interaction between them
to make sure that they can't
both be true and false.
Basically, you want
these things to point
in whenever possible because
then these guys can go down.
Otherwise, you would collide.
And if this guy's in,
the corresponding guys
in the bottom must
be down, and that's
enforced by this long
thing, which is either
completely down
or completely up.
So when it's completely
down, these guys
all have to be
down, which is going
to be a problem down below
if things aren't satisfied.
When it's up, all of these
guys would have to be up.
Some of them could be
up if you feel like it,
but really, you'd
probably put them
all down whenever you
can because then you
can take these guys
and stick them down.
So this is how
you set variables,
and then the other
things I showed
were clauses, essentially.
At least one of those
pins had to be pushed down
and you don't know which one,
and that's the hard part.
Rough sketch of how
this proof looks.
One thing is here,
for this to work,
these edges can't be spinnable.
When I go here, I must
immediately go back down.
I can't flip it.
So these are rigid edges.
That's not really
the original problem,
but you can simulate
rigid edges,
and this is where
the angles get small.
You can simulate rigid edges
with a very sharp zigzag
because if you ever
flipped one of these,
it would collide with
the previous edge.
So for sufficiently
sharp angles,
you can force parts to stay
straight in this funny way,
which is not great, but
it's one way to force it.
We can also do it with trees
or various other techniques,
but that's how the proof looks.
So that is flattening fixed
angle chains, strongly NP hard.
We go next to one
more topic for fun.
This is the topic of flips.
I guess I have an
image for this.
This is a problem
posed by Paul Erdos,
I think when he was a student.
He was a very famous
mathematician.
1935, he asked this question.
This is the whole question
as originally written.
You have a polygon and you take
the convex hull of the polygon,
and you take these regions
which are in the convex hull
but outside the polygon.
We call those pockets.
And you imagine
flipping those outside,
reflecting through
that supporting line,
that tangent on the outside,
so then you get this polygon.
Here you get two pockets.
Maybe you flip both of them, and
then you get a convex polygon.
Now you have no pockets,
and so you're done.
And the question is as posed.
Prove that after a finite
number of such steps,
the polygon would become convex.
So you might call this
a conjecture by Erdos
that it is finite.
He'd never published a proof.
There's one issue with
the problem as stated.
You can't actually
flip both pockets
at once if you want
to avoid collisions.
The relation to
linkages is we imagine
these flips could actually
happen by a rotation,
but you could also
just imagine them
as reflecting instantaneously.
There's this issue.
If you flip two
pockets at once, you
might have collisions
afterwards.
The way this problem has been
interpreted by most people
is don't flip them all at once.
Just flip them one
at a time, and then
you guarantee, because
this is a supporting line,
a tangent line, of
the convex hull,
when you flip one pocket out,
it will go to the other side
so it can't intersect
the rest of the polygon.
So you would avoid collision
if you do one flip at a time.
Now, this was observed, I
guess, a few years later
by Bela de Sz.
Nagy, and he also
published the first proof.
Before we get there,
a weird property
and why you might worry about
this being finite or infinite
is if you take
this quadrilateral
and make this very narrow,
this edge very small
relative to the
horizontal edge, then
you can require arbitrarily
many flips to convexify.
Even for n equals 4, you
could require a million flips.
So definitely there's
some dependence
on the ratio between the longest
length and the smallest length,
though in open
problem, what we still
don't know is whether you
can bound the number of flips
in terms of n and that ratio.
Is it pseudo-polynomial?
Who knows?
So it turns out
it's always finite,
and there have been many proofs
over the years of this result.
It's kind of been
rediscovered many times.
Nagy solved it originally
in 1939, and he cited Erdos.
These two guys
didn't cite anyone,
so they may have come up with
the problem independently.
This paper, these are
two Russian proofs.
Then this paper cited--
they knew about everything.
They cited all of them.
They cited Reshetnyak.
I don't think they necessarily
knew about Yusupov.
Independently, Kaluza
posed the problem in 1981
and Wegner solved it, and
then to finally clean it up,
Grunbaum, who we saw
from un-un-unfoldable,
knew about everything.
Presumably, this is everything.
Of course, we might
have missed one.
But he knew all the above,
came up with his own proof.
And then Godfried
Touissant, father
of computational geometry,
one of them, knew about these
and came up with yet
another, simpler proof.
So the story of
this is kind of fun.
When I taught this class for
the very first time, 2003 or so,
I thought, OK, cool.
This is a classic theorem.
Everyone should know it.
So I thought I'd cover the
latest proof that's presumably
the best, so I covered
Godfried's proof.
I was a little unhappy with
it, but I finished writing down
the proof, and then one of
the students raised their hand
and asked, is that really right?
Can you do that in step two?
And the answer was
no, you can't do that.
It basically skipped a step.
And so I thought, oh gee.
And so I corresponded
with O'Rourke and Godfried
that weekend and was like,
is something missing here?
Maybe we should go back to
some of the other proofs
because we've got
lots to choose from.
So we went to the original,
which is a very short proof.
It's only one page long,
maybe one and a half pages.
And so this is fun.
This is 1939, the way
mathematics used to be done.
And it's funny because
Grunbaum's proof was based
on Nagy's proof and
Toussaint's proof
was based on Grunbaum's
proof, so in the end,
these proofs were very similar.
In fact, they differed
exactly in the one step,
which was kind of omitted here.
So I thought, OK great.
Here we have a fill-in
on how to do it.
And so the next class, I
went up and I presented it.
I was really happy.
Isn't this cool,
1939 mathematics?
It's really awesome,
and it's one line
that filled in this step.
The same student raises
his hand and is like,
I don't think that's true.
So now the step was filled
in but it was wrong.
So it turns out actually
most of these proofs
are wrong, but not all
of them, fortunately,
so the theorem is still true.
So that one was wrong, this one
was wrong, this one was wrong,
this one skipped a
step that was key,
this one essentially also
skipped the step that was key.
So in the end, there's two
correct proofs, Reshetnyak
and Bing and Kazarinoff,
which was surprising.
So I thought I'd show you one
of the errors in the Nagy proof.
There's one other
interesting feature here,
which is, why wasn't this
discovered until our class?
The student was Blaise Gassand,
and so then we wrote a paper
about it and we have our
own proof, of course.
Now, some people
may have realized
there was an error in
some of the proofs.
Bing and Kazarinoff, one of
the correct proofs, a very nice
one, wrote-- here's the
original Russian sentence.
The English translation
is, "the proof
of this theorem given
by Nagy is incorrect,"
which leaves something
to be desired.
And Grunbaum, who
can read Russian--
we had to get them
translated-- mentioned this.
So he noticed that point. "They
remarked that Nagy's proof is
invalid but there's no
basis for this claim."
Then it remained undiscovered
until 2005 or something.
Kind of funny.
Good thing there's so many
proofs to choose from.
So this is Nagy's
original proof.
You can see the example
where flipping two pockets
simultaneously
causes a crossing.
Don't read the whole
thing, obviously,
but there's one
sentence here which is,
if you take a polygon, call
it p0, and you flip a pocket
and you get p1, and you flip
a pocket and you get p2,
and you take the convex
hull of p and you get c0,
and you take the convex hull
of p1 and you get c1, p2,
you get c2.
And then you interleave
these polygons
so that the polygon is a convex
hull, next polygon is a convex
hull, because you're
always flipping out,
each of these polygons obviously
contains the foregoing ones.
And so that seemed really
nice and we thought,
oh, this is so elegant.
They used this to prove that
the limit of the p's is convex
because the limit
of the p's then
would be the limit of the c's
because it was interleaving.
But it's not true
that these things
contain the previous ones
because if you have two pockets
and you flip one of
them, it's this one
pocket versus multiple
pockets issue.
If you flip one of
them, that will not
contain the convex
hull of the original
because you haven't
flipped them all.
If you flipped all the
pockets, than you would contain
the convex hull of
the original, but that
would end up arguing
that some flip
sequences work, not all of them.
So this is annoying,
and I think this
is where I run out of slides.
But we have some time, so I can
give you a sketch of the proof.
This is the Bing and Kazarinoff
proof or our version of it.
Give you an idea
of how this works.
It's an easy proof, it's just
easy also to get it wrong
or to skip one of the steps.
I will just do a proof
by picture, I think.
So suppose you have a
polygon on the plane,
and let's say you flip a pocket.
So this would look
something like that.
A little hard to
do a reflection.
So this is the
reflective polygon,
and if we look at each of
the vertices over here,
these guys don't move,
these guys moved over here,
reflecting through that line.
Observation one.
If I take some point x
interior to the polygon,
then these points that move
get farther away from x.
Why?
Because if you look
at this line here,
let's say you look at a
vertex and where it goes.
This line is the Voronoi
diagram of those two points.
This is the perpendicular
bisector of this and this.
That's the meaning
of reflection.
So that means everything
to the left of the line
here is closer to this
point than that point.
Everything to the
right of the line
is closer to this
point than that point.
Now x, which is
interior to the polygon,
must be to the left of the
line because the whole polygon
is to the left of the line.
So distance from x to
this vertex increases.
I mean, x will remain
inside because as you flip,
you only get bigger.
So if I take a point x
and I look at the distance
to some vertex, it can only
monotonically increase.
It also can't get
arbitrarily large
because the maximum
it could possibly be
is half the perimeter
of the polygon.
The perimeter of the
polygon is preserved
so it can only stretch so far.
So if you look at this distance,
it's monotonically increasing
and it's bounded because
it can never get bigger
than the perimeter
of the polygon.
Therefore, it has a limit.
That distance has
a limit because
monotone bounded sequences
always have a unique limit.
So cool.
Distance from x to some
vertex has a limit.
Well, I'm going to do this for
three different points, x, that
lie on some non-degenerate
triangle, so not all on a line.
That means the three
distances from these points
to this vertex all
converge to some limit.
And therefore, that
point converges
to a limit, namely the
intersection of those three
circles centered
at those points.
So this proves that
the polygon has
a limit because every
vertex has a limiting point.
Cool.
Now the tricky part is to
argue that limit is convex,
and this is where
everyone had an issue.
The first thing we argue is that
the angles converge to a limit.
This is kind of a
technicality because we
know the points
converge to a limit,
so surely the angle does.
The only issue is, well,
if all the points converge
to the same point, then the
angle would not have a limit,
but that's easy to
argue can't happen
because these edge
links are preserved.
So I will just skip that one.
It follows from some
of the things we said.
Now we get to the fun part.
This polygon has a limit.
The angles have limits.
So I want to look at
the limiting angles.
I want to in particular
look at the vertices that
move because if you flip an
infinite number of times, that
means some vertex must move
an infinite number of times,
because every time you
flip, somebody moves.
These guys are
considered not moving
even though they're kind
of involved in the flip.
So if you look at the moved
guys, what is their angle?
So before, there
was some angle here,
and afterwards, the interior
angle is the reverse.
If this was reflex
before, it's convex now.
If there were a convex
angle over here like this,
it would become
reflex over here.
You alternate between
being less than 180
and greater than 180
every time you move.
So if you have a vertex that is
moving infinitely many times,
its angle must alternate
between less than 180 convex
and greater than 180 reflex
infinitely many times.
If that happens and you
have a unique limit angle,
your limit angle must be 180.
That's interesting.
If our vertex moves
infinitely many times,
then its limit angle
equals 180, must be flat.
Very close to a
contradiction at this point.
These guys are going to
end up looking like this.
Well, let's look
at the other guys.
So we have some limit polygon.
In the limit polygon, there
are some flat vertices,
but there must also be
some non-flat vertices.
You can't just go straight
and hope to close a cycle.
So there's maybe some
convex ones like this.
There may be some reflex ones.
At some point,
these vertices must
stop moving because everyone
who moves infinitely many times
has a limit angle flat.
So anybody who is--
we call it "pointed"
here, although it's a little
different from pointed pseudo
triangulations.
Anyone who's not
a flat angle must
stop moving after finite time.
So let's go to that time
when all of these guys
have stopped moving.
So your limit
polygon is something.
We don't know whether
it's convex or whatever.
It could have many flat angles.
It's got to have at
least one of them
if we assume there's
something infinite here.
This is the limit polygon.
Now, at finite time,
we know that these guys
have stopped moving, meaning
we're done with those guys.
I've drawn the limit here, but
also the finite thing, which
must be on the inside, right?
This must be
something like this.
Somehow it's going to flip and
reach the infinitely many times
and reach this in the limit.
Hm.
That looks weird.
So the way to argue
this in the clean way
is if you look at the
convex hull of the limit,
let's say, convex hull
of the limit is this.
And look at the convex
hull of this finite time
when the squared vertices
have stopped moving.
Convex hull will
be-- well, it's got
to be at least this because
these guys are already there.
The convex hull is defined
by the square points.
You don't care about
the flat vertices.
That won't affect
the convex hull.
So that means the convex
hull equals the limit convex
hull at this finite time.
Now you're about to
do another flip, which
means you're going to
go outside that convex
hull and contradiction.
Is that clear?
Maybe go through that
part one more time.
After finite time, when all
of the non-flat vertices
have stopped moving, we have
reached the final convex hull.
That means you can't do any more
flips because every flip makes
the convex hull
bigger, so you actually
had to stop at that time.
That's kind of a fun proof.
The key is really this
part, that if a vertex flips
infinitely many times, then
that limit angle must be flat,
and so they really don't
participate in the convex hull.
This is the Bing and
Kazarinoff key idea.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
Does anyone do this for 3D?
PROFESSOR: 3D is a good.
People have tried to
define flips for 3D,
and I think there's never really
been a successful definition.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and
exactly how to flip it.
I mean, you can define
pocket in the same way,
but then the boundary
won't be a single plane.
It'll be some convex
cap, and so flipping, you
can't really just reflect.
It's kind of annoying.
AUDIENCE: The
other question was,
you have a sequence
of simple operations
that takes you from
non-convex to convex.
Does anybody use that
in a proof to say,
these things are preserved
across the operations?
You said perimeter
was preserved.
What about shortest paths?
PROFESSOR: So is this
useful for something?
Shortest paths are
certainly not preserved.
Edge lengths are preserved.
Of course, we know how to do
that with the carpenter's rule
theorem, just staying in 2D,
so it's not that exciting.
But the operations are
definitely a lot simpler.
I think the easy
answer to your question
is there are many
natural, simple moves,
and this is the first one
that people considered,
but actually, there
are a lot more,
and I'm going to
talk about those.
The main application I know
for this stuff is basically,
people wanted to generate random
closed walks in 3D typically,
and so they wanted to find
a small set of operations
they could just perform
randomly and hope
that that was a rapidly
mixing Markov chain,
so eventually, you'd have
a kind of random thing.
I don't think there
are any rapid mixing
results, at least
that I'm aware of.
In order to hope to
get the space randomly,
you would at least have to
be able to make anything.
So for that, the question is,
can you convexify anything,
because if you can convexify
anything, then at least
you can make anything,
more or less.
So that's where these
questions come from.
We focus more on
the universality,
but I think what people care
about is this random generation
business.
To that end, of course,
for random generation,
you don't really
care about crossings.
And so another fun
extension which
was in, I think, our
paper for the first time,
although there's a weaker
version in Grunbaum's paper,
if you start with a
non-crossing, this proof
still works.
You need to add a little
more to the argument.
Either you decrease the number
of crossings, which can only
happen a finite number of times,
or this kind of stuff works.
You can make crossing polygons,
too, which is kind of cool.
So that's the end
of basic flips.
Then we have something called a
flip turn, which is kind of fun
and in some ways better behaved,
and gets to your question
of what else is preserved.
So let's say you have
a pocket like this.
So normally with a
flip, we would reflect.
With a flip turn, you reflect
and then also flip this way,
so it's the same as rotating
180 degrees about the center.
In addition to
preserving perimeter,
this preserves the
edge directions.
This matches this, this matches
this, this matches this.
It does not preserve
the edge order, however.
Here, we preserve
the edge order.
Here, we've reversed the
order of those three edges.
So all this is really
doing is permuting
the sequence of edges.
The edge directions and the
edge lengths are all the same.
So this means you could make
at most n factorial moves here.
Immediately, it's different
from this situation
where even for n
equals 4, you could
have arbitrarily many moves.
Here, it's at most n factorial.
That was the original bound.
It turns out every
polygon convexifies
after order n
squared flip turns.
It's a fun proof but I don't
have time to cover it here.
That's flip turns.
Then we go to deflations.
This is the inverse of a flip.
So suppose you take a polygon
and you do an operation
that, if flipped, would result
in the original polygon,
exactly the opposite of a flip.
This was conjectured to also
finish after finite time,
but in fact it doesn't.
If you take any quadrilateral
satisfying Kawasaki,
so if you add up the
opposite edge lengths
and they're equal-- so 6
plus 3 is 9, 4 plus 5 is 9--
then there it is at least
a flat limit possibly.
That's the Kawasaki thing.
And in fact, it will
converge to that flat limit
and it will take infinite
time to get there.
So that's kind of fun.
It gets very hard to
draw the pictures.
This is really the main example
of an infinitely deflating
polygon.
We have a paper called
"Deflating the Pentagon," which
got some fun political
views at some point.
It's about a
pentagon, five sides.
And essentially, unless you have
a flat vertex, in which case
you are quadrilateral, there
is no infinitely deflating
pentagon, which means you can
deflate the pentagon always
in finite time.
It is open for
hexagons and higher
whether there is another
example different
from the quadrilateral.
Then there's the idea of a pop.
This is an even simpler
operation than a flip.
You just take two
edges, like here we're
taking these two edges,
and, ignoring crossings,
you just flip as if
that were a pocket lid,
so if this were a pocket.
Then you get this polygon.
Now here, you can be
forced to get crossings.
No matter how you flip,
you might get a crossing.
Still, we're wondering--
who cares about crossings--
are pops enough to make
anything, or to convexify?
And the answer is no.
There's this set of polygons
called alternating polygons
where the vertices
alternate between the x-axis
and the y-axis.
And you can prove that no
matter what pop you do,
you are still an
alternating polygon,
and alternating polygons,
you can also prove,
are never convex,
so you're stuck.
This was open for many years but
finally solved a few years ago.
There's also pop turns, which
is where you take two edges
and you do a 180 degree
rotation like this.
And there, we can prove
if you allow crossings,
you can convexify any polygon.
I don't have a figure of that
because it's just an algorithm.
We haven't actually run
it on a nice example.
If you avoid crossings, we can
characterize when it's possible
and when it's impossible.
And those are pretty much
all the simple operations
that at least have been studied.
There's probably more to
think about, but that's it,
and that's the end of
my part of the class.